Montaine je tiens à vous le dire je suis
dans une forme olympique je veux pas
vous mettre la pression mais aujourd'hui
il va falloir que ça envoie il va
falloir que ça tabasse
c'est désormais officiel voici le
nouveau gouvernement il y a d'abord ceux
qui partent faute d'avoir convaincu à
commencer par Pape Ndiaye ministre de
l'Éducation il n'a pas réussi à imprimer
sa marque une promotion de taille pour
celui qui a débuté comme porte-parole
dans mars en 2018 et qui occupait
jusqu'ici le poste de ministre des
comptes publics Papé N'Diaye pourtant
choisi par le chef de l'État en personne
n'aura donc pas tenu beaucoup plus qu'un
an à ce poste Emmanuel Macron qui a dit
avant-hier au ministre on peut
collectivement être fier de ce qui a été
fait ces derniers mois on vient juste de
vivre une séquence absolument
terrifiante dans le pays bon exit aussi
Marlène Schiappa secrétaire d'État
chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire la polémique sur la gestion du
fond Marianne et ses photos dans Playboy
auront eu raison de son sort
vu sa tactique c'est pas une spécialiste
des acrobaties
[Applaudissements]
c'est probablement le tir le plus
efficace depuis le début Tracy défend
férocement ces 5000 dollars ce
remaniement c'est finalement la prime au
fidèle Aurore berger actuel président
des députés Renaissance à l'Assemblée
devient ministre des Solidarités à la
place de Jean-Christophe combe enfin les
piliers gardent leur poste Bruno Le
Maire à l'économie
Gérald Darmanin garde l’intérieur et
toujours Sébastien Lecornu au ministère
des armées Catherine Colonna à l'Europe
et aux Affaires étrangères enfin
Christophe Béchu et Olivier Véran un ton
menacé reste au gouvernement quel verbe
pour deux points dérivés du mot terre et
synonymes de consterné
[Musique]
exactement
l'économie Nicolas dose nos courses
alimentaires à l'heure de l'inflation le
changement de comportement est massif
oui j'ai dit à Damien cette nuit si il y
a des choses neuves il dit bon on le
sait bah oui évidemment il y a des
choses neuves pour moi l'occasion de
répondre à la plusieurs centaines de
personnes qui m'ont insulté hier quand
j'ai dit que les salaires commençaient à
rattraper les prix ouh là là
et de fermer les yeux quelques minutes
on appelle ça aussi la sieste cette
entreprise spécialiste du déménagement
pour les particuliers la institué les
mini ventilateurs dans ces grands
bureaux ne suffisent pas aux 50 salariés
bon je pense qu'on est en train de péter
les plombs littéralement je pense qu'on
est dans un monde parallèle je pense que
X-Files c'est parmi nous ce que le
comment il s'appelait la meule de
rescully là ils sont avec nous vous avez
pété les plombs il y a une semaine il
faut pas travailler plus de 33 degrés
droits droit droit au retrait
aujourd'hui c'est droit à la sieste mais
c'est quoi la semaine prochaine mais
c'est quoi la semaine prochaine
mais vous êtes dans un monde parallèle
on a quand même des journées qui sont
très chargées faut tenir il y a le café
c'est sûr mais la sieste à midi elle est
pas mal vraiment
cet instant de relaxation est nécessaire
il est même programmé pour la
responsable des ressources humaines cela
contribue à une meilleure organisation
du travail on est en crise on n'a pas de
pognon tout augmente l'inflation il y a
pas assez de doigt d'argent pour aller
en vacances mais on a le droit à la
sieste pas travailler au-dessus 33 ça
veut dire quoi on va ou sinon moi j'ai
moi j'ai un projet d'accord on fait quoi
on fait l'été et l'hiver congés payés
payés par l'État et on travaille autant
de printemps comme son travail de saison
et de saison comme ça la France elle va
aller magnifiquement bien l'Europe elle
va continuer à couler dans des pays du
Sud un groupe d'adeptes de frères et Man
qui prévoyait le bouleversement général
pour le 14 juillet à 13h45 c'est préparé
à affronter les affres d'une survie
terrestre quand tout le reste aurait
sombré dans la violence d'une apocalypse
alors dites pourtant rien et frère et
Mans spectateur et prophète et rester
sur sa faim avec tout son monde il a
cependant expliqué avec le plus grand
sérieux qu'il s'était trompé dans ses
calculs et que la fin du monde aurait
lieu quand elle aurait lieu dans ton
garage midi si quelqu'un a tes salariés
dit après le déjeuner là j'ai un coup de
pompe il fait chaud etc est-ce que je
peux dormir un quart d'heure de pause
sur l'heure de pause tu rajoutes pas un
quart d'heure si je rajoute je lui
ramène aussi une strip-teaseuse et je
lui ramène aussi après
moi aussi qu'est-ce que non mais non
mais dans ce cas-là non mais je suis pas
une association caritative
gouvernementale à but non lucratie non
mais explique il faudrait faire la
sieste systématiquement au travail pour
retrouver une deuxième capacité de de
concentration l'après-midi 20 minutes
pas plus car ensuite le réveil est plus
difficile et se remettre dans le rythme
du travail peut s'avérer plus compliqué
la désindustriels
c'est pas la gauche maintenant
mesdames et messieurs Mitterrand
François Mitterrand était le président
du RPR à l'époque voilà c'est d'après
Barbara Lefebvre mais c'est horrible non
non non moi j'ai de la trouille de ces
trucs là
mais comment on peut avoir ça
comment peut avoir ça dans sa chambre à
coucher
il essaie de vous mordre là et comment
comment vous faites pour qu'il vous
mordent pas il faut être doux
c'est quoi ce sont mes quatre enfants on
s'était déguisés en zombie pourquoi des
zombies pourquoi pas rassurez-moi vous
ne rapportez pas chez vous des petites
pilules de l'hôpital
il essaye de mordre là il ouvre la
bouche
et il est dangereux
également
morsure également facile c'est le
troisième plus dangereux au monde
[Rires]
pris dans les phares d'une voiture
l'animal apparaît dans la nuit une
silhouette de félin une lionne décrivent
les deux témoins de la scène suffisant
pour créer la panique dans cette
banlieue sud de Berlin depuis police
hélicoptère et chasseur participent à la
traque du fauve sous les yeux des
habitants pas très rassuré
les télévisions allemands vont donc
relayé toute la journée des appels à la
prudence attention un dangereux animal
est en liberté qui promenade en forêt
interdite à Clyde marneff ou l'animal a
été vu les habitants de cette zone à
quelques kilomètres du sud-ouest de
Berlin sont également appelés à réduire
leur déplacements
je dois être honnête j'ai un peu paniqué
parce que c'est un autre calibre par
rapport à un chien normal ou un autre
animal qui peut courir
donc je vais rentrer maintenant je vais
rentrer chez moi
j'ai deux petits teckel qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que j'en pense que c'est la
nourriture idéale pour les lions
on s'est aperçut très rapidement que
cette fenêtre réfléchissante en quelque
sorte elle nous protégeait et qui nous
voyait absolument pas donc on a pu faire
plein d'images ça doit être plusieurs
minutes ensuite il a fait le tour de la
maison puis il est revenu etc donc
c'était un vrai luxe pendant près d'une
heure et demie ou le Link ça a tourné
autour de la maison je vais donc vous
demander quels sont les états souverains
qui sont aujourd'hui des monarchies oh
on doit citer les monarchies dans le
monde c'est-à-dire tous les châteaux non
non non les monarchies avec un roi
[Musique]